single guy this is a couple of these
single guy marrying a woman with
multiple kids
oh stupid guy
woman multiple kids
many kids
she's got a couple kids yeah oh hell
nobody brian austin green hell nah bro
yeah um that's a dub single mothers are
recreational use only
you don't you don't marry those women
that's that's a bad move for you why
because of the baggage because of the
kids because of the just there's far too
much risk i mean
well we already know that marriage is is
terrible for men in general you get
marrying a single mother now you're
bringing kids into the equation that
you're going to have to provide and
protect for that aren't your own seed
and that woman breaks up with you now
you're going to get hit with a double
wham you have you lose her and the kids
that you built at the natasha is that
the biggest l you can take it's it's
going to be the worst l you can take
marrying a single mom is very bad it's
not it's it's not in your best as a man
it is not in your best interest to marry
a single mother i know but oh my god
that's so [ __ ] up the reality is when
you look at it from from a logical
perspective you take on way too much
risk because now you might lose that
woman and then on top of that every kid
that you build an attachment with and
here's the other part you have no legal
rights to those children because they're
not yours and i did it so i know you did
it you married a single mom yep
what'd that look good how'd that work
out uh honestly speaking like it was a
cool relationship with me and her just
that the other element of the kid being
there um when i was young i didn't
understand what it really was and two um
they tell you up front well some of them
tell you oh you know what don't worry
about a kid i'm gonna take care of him
it's my responsibility over time is like
you're gonna have to at some point chip
in or be a part of it so it's like
as a young guy coming out if you're
single with no kids honestly speaking
your best strategy is to have a woman
that has no kids as well because that
burden that's not your burden can be
a lot to like deal with so and a single
dad is not the same as a single mom like
a single dad is attractive to other
women a single mom is
i mean hey she could be attractive but
don't take herself is that true do you
think are you ladies attracted to single
dads dad bod vibes not for me no no
jenny i've been with a guy that has kids
and is it attractive to you
like when he's taking care of his kids
and doing all that is that what admires
him that's why i was with him it wasn't
that's it love okay love like be where
it is but she was attracted to him
because he displayed social proof of
having children and being able to
provide a provision for them too you
might not acknowledge that but um
that can definitely add value because
you see how how he treats a kid and you
would want him to treat your kids like
that but he asked you were you attracted
to and you kind of like just i was
attracted to him because of love i
didn't know he had kids when i met
him okay
speed round he wrote the connection and
then he told me he has kids um i'm sure
you knew about the kids prior to you
loving him
that's probably true prior to me loving
him but before you said i love you to
him you probably knew that he had
children and had a former relationship
with a woman correct yes okay so
he was attractive then therefore you
were like okay i can build some of this
guy and then eventually led to love but
you knew he had kids which whether you
know you want to admit it or not
subconsciously a man that has kids is
more attractive because he's able to
display he's able to protect
protect children he's um he's not weird
he's not psycho etc this is why men that
have dogs are more attractive because
they're able to care for a living
creature and he's not a psycho i will
say this yeah i i mean i don't know if
it's more attractive or not as
attractive but it there isn't there is
an attraction there because you're
seeing how he can foster kids and you
would hope that he could possibly ask
that you said no
i didn't say no i said love she said
love i will say what what were you
attracted to by that love attracted me
he attracted me his kids added valley to
it
does that make sense speed round guys
let's keep it we'll continue okay you're
the one that needs to leave soon yeah
okay i will say that i frequently um
consistently borrow some of my best
friend's kids and just take them out of
the town and just pick up ladies with
the kids
i'll glad them in the house just get a
dog just get a dog
dogs are
very high maintenance all right last few
um if you forget we were playing a speed
round ladies and gentlemen we just went
off to richter's tale
um
harry and megan i'm talking about prince
mother and harry
and the woman that he married meghan
markle
finesse he got finessed hell yeah well
stupid stupid shouldn't have done it
what would you have done if you're a
full-on prince of england what would you
do
just that's tough bro i mean that
position bro it's a lot of
responsibility and
you like who you like however
for the lineage and for my dynasty bro
that's a that's a dub bro yeah that's an
l big l
no no interest in that all right last
few justin timberlake and justin
justin timberlake and jessica beale just
got divorced does this do anything for
you guys heartbreaking oh big justin
timberlake fans anything and she's such
a great woman once again i'm surprised
once again things can be good up front
things might go by later on
and then it's bad i mean yeah not
surprised i mean this is so cool they're
both super high earnings she was not a
hoe so why are you not surprised like
because let me who initiated that
divorce guaranteed is probably her
do we know i don't know i don't know
i'll i'll have my uh my researcher find
out last few okay um
justin bieber and hayley baldwin
thoughts on their relationship she made
him better
i don't know enough to they seem good
i'll say once again once again teen love
i mean love that that i agree with on
that one wait are they married yeah yeah
how old is he is he like he's got to be
like 27 i would have guessed he's oh
he's always like 20 no he's like 28.
eric can i get a justin bieber age right
quick i think we're the same age
i say all the time in today's day and
age you shouldn't be getting married
until you're at least 35. that was my
next question for you
as a man what are you doing consider
getting married so i have this is my
thing that i tell guys i think 35 years
old
35 years old had slept with at least 50
women 100k per year you're in shape
and uh you got six months to one year of
savings
you